And he does go after him there...
...to lose a fastball which shot to the upper deck caught by that fan right there.
Nice grab.
Oh, wow!
Oh! There it goes.
Well, she's only doing what she sees them do all the time...
...and that is to throw the ball back on the field.
But you know when that happens,...
...the parent is never able to catch them before they end up doing it.
And there's a whole host of fans underneath that gentleman right there...
...who are looking for another souvenir.
Well, he just missed that ball, as he fouls that ball.
Oh! Nice grab, far back.
She says, "Well, let me have it."
"Let me have it, Dad. Thanks!"
Well, here it goes.
That little girl is gonna be looking for a baseball for the rest of the game.